beef cheeks just think the size of your
little cheeks yeah imagine the size of a
cow with them and the cheek is right
underneath here yeah I want you to give
them a really nice season with salt and
pepper on there please so bee cheeks
very cheap they cut that takes sort of a
long time to cook yeah but give it a bit
of love let it cook in the oven it comes
out like a dream a little touch
of oil in the pan what we want to do is
get them really nicely colored [ __ ]
steer into the pan oh cool lay away
see what that is
um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the
beach beach
no matter what the onion chunky cook it
for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
down
and then again there and there so it
doesn't overcook
so a really good color on the cheeks
like that so how do you cook these at a
restaurants if they take so long they go
in the oven literally how about six
seven o'clock in the morning three and a
half four hours we're ready for lunch
and the longer you leave them in their
juices yeah and the cooking liquor the
better King ice closer garlic good
onions in and garlic in please nice
where's your Bailey there it is yes
get those onions and that garlic really
nicely colored
put the cheeks back in place right red
wine in cool okay the red wine is going
to deglaze the pan so deglaze will
basically sort of rinse all that flavor
off the bottom of the pan yeah okay
because that's going to make the most
amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree but
chopped canned tomatoes you'll make a
much better sauce I'm going to top that
with some stock so the secret of
braising is having little of the meat
exposed and 90 of it submerged see them
there yeah they're like little crocodile
heads popping up out the water turn the
gas off and leave the lid just off at
the end there if we had to cover it
completely the steam hits the top yeah
the lid and all that water comes running
back it's solar still that's right in
the oven
140 150 for about three and a half to
four hours good job
Boom for pudding I'm making one of my
absolute favorite Italian desserts panna
cotta with that quintessential Italian
flavoring espresso
start by immersing two leaves of
gelatine in cold water and leave to soak
into a small saucepan add caster sugar
cream milk
sugar and a shot of good strong coffee
[Music]
bring to a simmer and remove from the
hob
[Music]
squeeze out the soaked gelatin leaves
and stir into the hot cream until
completely dissolved
foreign
mixture into a jug and fill your molds
just short of the rim rinsing your molds
in cold water before filling will make
it easier to get your panna cotta out
once it's set
[Music]
leaving the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
[Music]
your cinnamon hazelnut brittle pour
caster sugar into a pan and cook over
medium Heat
until the sugar melts to a deep golden
brown
[Music]
scatter toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel
dust with ground cinnamon and leave to
set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm given each
mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
[Music]
dress with a Shard of crunchy hazelnut
brittle nothing could be so deliciously
elegant
right Captain Jack quick run through
Panna cottas are nearly set beef cheeks
I need it cooked we're gonna now do the
Fig and brighter crostini oh okay let's
take the figs we're gonna make a nice
slightly spicy fig Jam take off the tops
yeah in half and each half into three
sugar a touch of salt in there
okay we're making a jam but we don't
want a bit too sweet and then these
little babies
what are they
ah what's the shape stars star
underneath stunnies taken from the
fantasy plant yeah and when you're
drying like that it's so intensifies the
flavor really important to count how
many put in there okay yeah so one two
three four five so they're just there
from flavors and take them out that's
right secret here let's get that camera
going so when I hear a jam I don't think
of caramel no but this is a very fast
Jam caramel's starting to color
I want you very carefully to drop the
figs in there good
so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the camera
you know what that is a little sweet
vanilla I love that on my challenge got
that sort of sweet and sour flavor leave
that cooking
for three four minutes
now let's slice our chapati in Italian
crostini means little bits of toast but
it could be made out of leftover
baguette sourdough or any crusty open
textured bread we're staying
authentically Italian with ciabatta
in them
and then drizzle a little touch of olive
oil on there both sides really important
because we're going to grill the bread
push it down
it's a lovely very lovely take it off
with the chapata toasted we need to
carefully extract the star on these pods
from our piping hot fig Jam
my Jack we've got one little bugger to
find oh no
look at that yes it is right now we've
got the green light to crush
[Music]
integrated in that caramel Alex so nice
oh Jack carefully spreads the crostini
with our hot fig Jam I can unveil the
last element to our starter the creamy
Italian specialty borata
[Music]
and little money bags
looking delicious this looks fun doesn't
it
we need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest can you imagine that sat
there and you tear some of that off and
you stick it on top of that and
um
um back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks I've chosen to use
papradelli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salt and first good olive
oil pasta in
twist it round so you don't break it no
bring that back up the ball that's going
to take that through
for four minutes
flat leaf parsley scrunch it up for me
yep and chop him now wait to see these
beef cheeks beauties
look at them
all except they're very soft going to
taste
so good
Jack you've just dribbled on your jumper
really right drain the pasta
salt pepper
pasta
little drizzle
of olive oil
I'm going to put your fresh pasta nicely
chopped nicely chopped
then this is the magic bit okay you take
a little Ladle of the juice
put that at the bottom and you put
pasta
on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
gonna love you even more now you know
what about when you cook this for your
girlfriend one day uh just tell her we
got the recipe for me promise promise I
don't want you stealing Daddy's Thunder
one
beautiful jaw on there two beautiful
Jaws on there
and then the third jaw and then you go
over
with the sauce how cool is that
delicious you've got the burrata
and I've got the cheeks
let's go baby
[Music]
don't be cheeky get it
my ultimate Italian dinner
quick fig Jam crostini with creamy
bodata a main course of slow cooked beef
cheek Ragu with Papa Deli and for
pudding espresso panna cotta with
cinnamon hazelnut brittle
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best Italian
tradition
first things first I'd like you to
season the students day
a nice spoon of flour
mix yeah good girl what's the flower
going to do dad the flower helps to
Brown the beef our seasoned flour will
also help to add flavor and thicken the
stew
marshmallows
you do feel a little bit marshmallow
don't they look at the size of the
chunks of the beef
I'm going to cut my carrots literally
similar similar sizes right does that
mean they'll cook equally that's right
now these are little pearl onions I'm
going to put them in whole as well
everything
has to stay the same otherwise it could
burn oh we've seen burn garlic before
I'm Matilda
promise you weren't going to mention
that
what is that
time time and what they
Bailey's Bailey's good girl tablespoon
of oil in the beef goes in first okay in
now
it's a beautiful color
remember the carrots thyme in good job
garlic pearl onions in
good
look at that really good mix up
food oh she's easy to make Daddy these
shoes are very easy to make providing at
the beginning you give it a little bit
of love
now that's all juicy browned
that thing that is beer and that's going
to deglaze the pan
adding beer or Stout helps to tenderize
the beef and give it a hearty delicious
flavor and that's the only way I want
you to taste beer
in a stew
yeah
I'm going to add in a couple of
teaspoons of tomato puree please
in fact three please
very nice
there's one final thing in there cover
this tuna steak with a big stock give
that a little mix with Danny please
wow that's really
funny it's not even cooked yet
all these vegetables in when you start
um serve it oh yes is the Garlic going
to be burnt no excuse me
right and we always put the lid with a
little bit just a little bit so it can
breathe not make the stew or watery into
the oven at 150 please tell us for about
two and a half hours and now
getting focused on your homework
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato Classics in one twice baked
bubble and Squid jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute and butter and add a dash of
water until tender
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and
cooked through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato Center
then Mash with a couple of knobs of
butter mix in the cabbage and season to
taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato Classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
right homework done yeah
she was chewing stewing let's get on
with our delicious hearty pet tart I've
been looking forward to this you and I
Chef I'm gonna prep the pears so if you
peel I'll top and tail into quarters
pears go soft in the oven very very
quickly so we're going to put them on a
tart we'll need to leave them whole half
or in quarter
what's that in there
Ginger that's right that's stem Ginger
so when you use stem Ginger and fresh
ginger next add your stem Ginger a
little of the stem ginger syrup good
girl and some brown sugar to your
quartered pears
and then just grate some fresh ginger
off you go so it's a bit of a different
one to grate this because it doesn't
really come through like the cheese no
I'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there right what we need to do
now is give that a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff we can make it so easy to do
so give me your finger
that's my center point I want you to get
the pairs going around like that in a
really nice Circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pairs keep on sliding all over the place
yeah so egg wash the outside and I'm
going to show you a little trick so you
lift that up
like a bit of a glue that's right
crimple this with our finger
the pastry forms this nice little shelf
like a little money bag are you going to
do anything with the spare pairs oh yeah
I'm building that up then you see
the fresh ginger
and those nice little bits of stem
Ginger let me go around my egg
be my glow just on top
Tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully
it's a bit like snow isn't it now that
glazes the pastry so the pastry has this
really nice shine on there as well
finally the lemon on top
put that there
180 and in she goes
can you smell the beef
[Music]
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it
just I was hoping you'd asked
taste
[Music]
how's that takes now
you're not allowed anymore
dumpling time flowering please I'm using
self-raising flour for a fluffy result
but if you like your dumplings hard use
plain flour next The Dumpling essential
suet that makes the dumplings nice and
moist
[Music]
by a generous dollop of grain mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers round Another
Touch of warm water here
your fingers are now a nice little whisk
fingers are getting tired right now put
your hand in there now you should bring
all that dough together
show you the best way to get that nice
and clean sprinkles and flour on your
hands rub them together
all that will come off
it's a good way is it now we've got this
wonderful dumpling mixture how squid is
that oh
a little flower on your hands okay roll
these lengthways
and then I want you to follow my lap in
your hand
I'll figure
smell that mustard in there
huh
come on
other trust you or something like that
yes please
tell me
gently let's go in at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center
put that back into the oven
20 minutes to cook the dumplings now if
you open the door for daddy I'm going to
take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our petard has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby
foreign would you like me to start
testing yes please
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job now very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look delicious okay
I'll check on the dumplings
now look they've sort of doubled in size
well definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
I might have to have a quick taste
before we go just to check I mean we
have to be sure we have to be
[Music]
ready
that is an amazing hearty beef stew
dumpling smoke the twice baked loaded
potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate Hearty dinner a
comforting Rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and Ginger galette